one of the worst places in the world to
be right now from the standpoint of
coronavirus is the US state of Florida
in total the United States is one of the
worst places to be like if you look at
just country level data but thankfully
for now some states in the United States
are actually doing pretty well but if
you look in more detail at the
state-by-state data there are some spots
in the United States that are the worst
places to be and that includes Arizona
that includes Texas that includes
California but certainly Florida is one
of those places Florida has 21 million
people that's more than many countries
have if Florida were a country it would
be one of the countries with the worst
outbreaks in the world right now in
terms of the growth rate of cases
Florida Republican state Rep Anthony
Sabatini went on CNN said Florida's
doing just fine now I'm gonna play some
clips for you he sounds completely
delusional he praised Governor Ron de
santis handling of the virus Ron de
santis the Florida Republican governor
is engaged in a battle with Georgia
governor Kemp and Texas governor Greg
Abbott for who has had the absolutely
worst response the outbreak in Miami is
being compared to the initial outbreak
in Wuhan China dr. Lillian [ __ ] said
quote Miami is now the epicenter of the
pandemic what we were seeing in Wuhan
six months ago five months ago now we
are there but Anthony Sabatini doesn't
care here he is by the way Sabatini I
feel like he's doing a disservice to the
Sabbatini named great Argentinean tennis
player Gabby Sabatini and Anthony
Sabatini shows up on CNN and tries to
tell Brianna Keilar that everything's
fine in Florida Brianna Keilar tries to
bring him back to reality
well Brianna I think what you're doing
is what a lot of folks in the middie
have done which is harp takes
exclusively on one metric namely the
cases cases cases cases the media is
almost exclusively focused on this one
number versus the two most important
numbers obviously hospitalizations and
fatalities were in most parts of the
state's flatlined er gone down
especially in mine so for now Sabatini
is just pushing the talking
cases don't really matter what matters
is hospitalizations what matters is
deaths but remember the cases are the
earliest indicator first you test
positive then you get sick enough to
have to go to the hospital then some
portion of those folks who go to the
hospital
die and case in point cases have been
exploding in Florida since around June
26 that's like 20 days ago death started
to spike a few days ago yesterday again
Florida set a new single day death
record and then they did it again I mean
multiple new single day death records in
Florida so deaths are spiking Anthony
Sabatini is pretending that they're not
but let's continue with the interview
and you're going to hear the state or
the state rep from Florida say Florida's
doing fine and DeSantis is doing great
and so if we focus on the two more
relevant metrics in Florida is doing
just fine
okay we focus on case positivity and we
just did a report on the metrics that
you cited perhaps you didn't hear it but
you've had actually in Leon County a
circuit judge who said and look we
checked representative we checked with
constitutional experts who said and this
is what the court judge said in this
this is what the circuit judge said and
constitutional experts agree with this
the ordinance because you lost in Leon
County the ordinance has a quote valid
basis to protect public health because I
mean you talk about this being an
extraordinary circumstance but we are in
an extraordinary circumstance we're in a
pandemic and Florida is not doing just
fine no they are but on the judge issue
there's about 800 Circuit Court Judge no
you say Florida is doing you think
Florida is doing fine right now
absolutely I think the governor's
response has been on point and I think
that the metrics that matter the most
we're doing very well and if you're
counting cases you're gonna scare people
but what they don't realize this okay
Susan deaths more or less 4521
total cases 300,000 last week
implementations increasing nineteen
thousand three hundred thirty four fifty
four Hospital I see us have reached
capacity in Florida another forty
hospitals show that I see us are at 10%
or less available
let me remind you you say you're doing
trees where the were the nation's third
largest state so out of the seventy
thousand new cases we had last week we
had about a hundred more people go to
the hospital that is a extremely small
number when you're looking at the fact
that we have 21 and a half million
people certainly not the sort of numbers
that would drive people to shut down the
economy global pandemic and you can't
even admit that that's actually a false
assessment entirely and I don't even
know what you mean by epicenter notice
that this is not about math we like to
think sometimes on the left naively that
if we just show them the numbers
everybody's going to get on the same
page everybody will understand what's
going on everybody will agree just show
them the numbers but it doesn't work and
yesterday we spoke to dr. Christopher
DeCarlo about critical thinking and
about data and statistics and it just
doesn't work that way and part of the
reason it doesn't work that way is you
have people like Anthony Sabatini and
Donald Trump just saying things that
aren't based in fact
going around saying Florida's fine we're
not the epicenter there's nothing to see
here
reality doesn't matter now on top of
this we also have to remember we have
much reason to think that we aren't even
really getting the true numbers out of
Florida we go back about a month six
weeks there were already allegations
that Florida was covering up or Mis
reporting data now officially as of two
days ago the Trump administration says
stop reporting to the CDC instead report
your data to HHS and Alex a czar Trump
tool Alex a czar who at one point hired
a labradoodle breeder to deal with the
day-to-day of coronavirus that was early
on so even with the numbers we're
getting out of Florida Florida's deaths
have hit new single day records multiple
times in the last week the last week in
total has been the worst week for
Florida in terms of cases in terms of
deaths but remember that on the tail end
of this the real data might be even
worse Florida is the epicenter of the
global pandemic at this point in time
and part of the reason why is they
insist everything's completely fine it's
like The Naked Gun scene with the great
comedic actor Leslie Nielsen where he's
saying please disperse
nothing to see here please disperse and
a building is exploding in the
background many of you know the scene
it's been the subject of a lot of
memeing on the internet that's
essentially what Anthony Sabatini is
doing here and it's absolutely insane
absolutely and utterly insane one of our
sponsors is privacy calm they're giving
you $5.00 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them any time you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cashback and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a twenty five dollar a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more
but definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm
/ Pakman